[Musique]
salut à tous cette semaine c'est sport
vous emmène au tournoi de tennis de
bagnoles de l'orne
un tournoi qui réunit des joueurs
classés au delà de la 400e place
mondiale
parmi eux nous avons suivi le normand
maxime forcin si sport c'est parti
[Musique]
au programme également ce soir du foot
le match entre le stade malherbe de caen
et l'olympique de marseille vient juste
de se terminer
on reviendra aussi sur toute l'actu
sportive de la semaine dans la région
enfin rencontre étonnante avec l'équipe
de hockey luge de sherco
exceptionnellement ce mardi c'est à la
maison que maxime peu goûté quelques
heures de repos davantage habituées aux
déplacements en france et en europe
s'est pour une fois à domicile que le
tennisman s'apprête à disputer le
tournoi de bagnoles de l'orne à
seulement 20 km de chez ses parents
moi c'est le seul de l'année où je peux
je peux être comme ça normalement voilà
on fait hôtel club
c'est ça notre quotidien en général on
arrive le matin on s'entraîne on
retourne à l'hôtel on mange au club
enfin voila c'est beaucoup de va et
vient
et voilà peu de temps au calme loin des
tournois du grand chelem depuis quelques
années le quotidien de maxime est celui
de tous les tennismen professionnels
classé au delà de la 250e place mondiale
des tournois de seconde zone du futur
indispensable pour progresser au
classement en gagnant quelques points
atp
mais rarement rentable une victoire au
premier tour important à peine 200 euros
sur le circuit tous ont passé plus ou
moins longtemps à l'image du granvillais
axel michon aujourd'hui 200 21e mondiale
tels aussi le cannet jules marie qui a
finalement décidé de se retirer des
tournois internationaux pour cause de
financement ont difficile d'une
trajectoire à l'autre maxime forcin lui
veut encore croire que tout est possible
on a tous le rêve de devenir un très
grand joueur donc on essaye et puis on
voit qu'au final peut jouer les joueurs
sans 50 100 250 mondial donc on voit qui
a pas énormément de différences
à 26 ans de retour de blessure depuis
deux mois le joueur espère rapidement
revenir au meilleur niveau
en attendant de grimper au classement il
doit jongler entre les tournois plus ou
moins lucratif sous le regard
bienveillant de ses parents projet bon
après on a ses limites et parce
qu'arrivé à un certain niveau il n'ya
plus que le talent qui conte est aussi
le budget est important dont
heureusement après ont été des choix à
faire on peut pas forcément en train
d'investir devant son public
maxime espère donc bien réussir son
retour gagnant cette semaine avant de
retrouver maxime pour son premier tour
ici au tournoi de bagnoles-de-l'orne
place au football la ligue 1 ce dimanche
le stade malherbe de caen recevait
l'olympique de marseille la rencontre
vient tout juste de se terminer
[Musique]
entre deux équipes en panne de victoire
en championnat
la fiche quand marseille s'annonçait
plutôt indécise mais la période
d'observation n'aura pas duré bien
longtemps
dès la 5e minute bien lancé en
profondeur ferrer manque l'ouverture du
score en tirant dans les bras de
mandanda
trois minutes plus tard le but d' hervé
bazile de retour dans l'effectif
caennais est refusé pour une position de
hors jeu
mais l'olympique de marseille n'est pas
en reste à la 12e minute
barrada fait le travail et passe a battu
à dix ballons repoussés mais trop tard
le but est validé par l'ailé phone à 1 0
le match ne perd pas pour autant son
rythme
l'ol pousse fort et batshuayi moncton
inscrire le doublé dans un match très
animé
le ballon passe rapidement d'un camp à
l'autre mais à la pause le score en
reste là
1 0 pour marseille à la reprise le
spectacle va rester au même niveau
les marseillais se montre à nouveau les
plus dangereux une fois deux fois à la
troisième et nous couvrons trouve le
cadre et aggrave la marque
les affaires se compliquent alors pour
le stade malherbe mais à la 67e minute
sur un coup franc de féret la tête de
ronny rodelin trompe le portier
marseillais à 2 1 caen peut encore
espérer
mais les normands ne trouveront plus le
cadre les dernières actions sont au
crédit d'un olympique de marseille
toujours très dangereux et à moins de
dix minutes du coup de sifflet final
bouna sarr vient des centres et enfonce
le clou d'une reprise bien senti le
troisième but marseillais douce les
derniers espoirs canet avec cette
nouvelle défaite 3 1 le stade malherbe
recule ce soir à la 6e place du
classement l'olympique de marseille fait
une nouvelle fois le break
autour à notre fil rouge
bienvenue à bagnoles de l'orne depuis
neuf ans en janvier
la ville thermale accueille son tournoi
de tennis catégorie futur les moins
dotés du circuit professionnel
à l'heure où les meilleurs mondiaux sont
à l'autre bout du monde pour l'open
d'australie dans l'orne
les joueurs viennent chercher quelques
points qui leur permettront de grimper
au classement atp
parmi eux le normand maxime forcin de
retour sur le circuit après un an
d'interruption pour blessure trois mois
à l'épaule sept mois au dos son objectif
désormais retrouver son niveau
alors avant l'entraînement séances de
massage et terrasse est toujours un
petit pépin donc il y en a qui sont plus
importants que d'autres mais vers en ce
moment c'est plutôt c'est plutôt pas mal
mon dos est vraiment presque minimes
maintenant parce que j'ai vécu l'année
dernière c'est presque rien donc je fais
ça surtout par prévention plutôt que que
de soigner le malade sur le court ce
mardi c'est le cannet jules marie qui
venu jouer le rôle de sparring partner
partenaire de club
les deux normands se connaissent bien
ils partagent désormais le même
entraîneur au sein du pôle élite créé
cette année au tennis club de caen
france initiative light enlève un peu de
temps ouvert il joue là bas tu réponds
par un chip un tir flottant diag oui
mais oui ça lui permet d'avoir une
proximité
ça lui permet de s'entraîner
régulièrement
intensément et donc oui c'est je pense
que c'est un avantage d'être à quelques
heures de son premier tour avec ses
derniers conseils maxime rentre déjà un
peu dans son match c'est très important
parce qu'il met en confiance voilà ils
ont fait mieux gérer l'avant match et
voilà sur de le reposer puis je serai
bien pour ça
avant de retrouver maxime pour son match
place au reste de l'actualité sportive
de la semaine dans la région
en basket lourde défaite vendredi pour
le cbc en blanc à domicile les cadets
recevaient chartray vont perdre pied de
le deuxième quart temps ils encaissent
10 points consécutifs et ne reviendront
pas à la pause les visiteurs mènent par
un écart de 18 points que les normands
ne réussiront pas à combler dominés dans
le jeu impuissant au rebond le cbc
s'incline finalement 67 à 88
un match à oublier au classement caen se
maintient à la sixième place de national
ou sous les paniers de la ligue féminine
mondeville s'incline cet après midi à
basket landes score 71 à 67 au
classement du sommet 9e en football en
championnat national des fêtes vendredi
pour le us avranches qui s'incline 2-1
aux herbiers
avranches redescend à la 8e place du
championnat de national en hockey sur
glace sombre soirée hier soir pour les
drakkars à nice caen s'incline
lourdement en encaissant neuf buts
contre aucun les normands sont 8e de
division une en athlétisme les
championnats régionaux en salle se
tenait ce week-end à mondeville
malgré quelques absences le haut niveau
normands avaient répondu présent au
programme marche sprint est lancé sow et
demi fond
aux profs france ce week end au mans
belle performance de la manchoise aurore
guérin un mois après une contre
performance aux championnats d'europe
elle termine première française 7e au
général derrière les 6 premiers
éthiopienne course à pied toujours avec
le traditionnel cross de beauregard ce
dimanche à hérouville-saint-clair 11
courses étaient au programme avec sur
les lignes de départ 600 coureurs au
total
parmi eux une soixantaine d'étrangers
des filles des patins à roulettes et du
spectacle tant accueillez ce week end la
deuxième étape du championnat de france
de roller derby
un sport en plein développement qui voit
s'affronter des équipes autour d'une
piste ovale
le but étant de dépasser les joueurs de
l'équipe adverse neuf rencontres étaient
au programme ce week-end
et puis le match des 16e de finale de
coupe de france entre granville et
sarreguemines se jouera le week end
prochain à guichet fermé mercredi toutes
les places disponibles se sont vendus en
seulement deux heures pour tous les
autres vous pourrez suivre la rencontre
entre les deux équipes de cfa 2 le
week-end prochain dans le fil rouge de
ces sports suite de notre fil rouge dans
les vestiaires du tournoi de tennis de
bagnoles de l'orne à quelques minutes de
son premier tour mise en chauffe pour
maxime forcin ce mardi le tirage au sort
a mis sur sa route le 650 7e joueur
mondial s'est jouée deux fois déjà
j'ai perdu deux fois donc ce soir un
match compliqué après j'ai rien à perdre
en le kg
comme maxime samuel bensoussan est un
habitué de ce circuit des tournois dits
futur des compétitions dans lesquelles
aucun match n'est facile et face à un
joueur tout en puissance cela débute mal
pour le joueur local maxime faire les
quatre premiers jeux et laisse
finalement la première manche à son
adversaire 6 3
dans la deuxième devant un public
l'armée va se réveiller plus précis plus
ils ont réussi maxime l'emportent si
joseph
[Musique]
une reprise et puis ils serviront je
sais bien qu'ils attaquent qu'il faut
malheureusement celui qui a des clés un
tripeux jcb qui qu'elle ait point n'est
plus et plus du plus fort ça savoir s'il
va pas faire trop trop à une manche
partout
la qualification pour les huitièmes de
finale va se jouer dans le troisième set
[Musique]
en attendant de faire des queues de
cette rencontre place à notre dossier il
est consacré cette semaine un sport
étonnant le hockey luge du hockey sur
glace adapté pour les personnes
handicapées
chaque semaine tout commence par un long
trajet trois heures de route aller
retour juste pour faire du sport
en l'absence d'une patinoire à cherbourg
il faut se rendre jusqu'à quand pour un
simple entraînement de hockey luge
tous viennent de la manche tous
souffrent d'un handicap moteur
la plupart sont en fauteuil roulant et
se sont mêlés aux quais il y a quelques
mois lors de la création de l'équipe
s'échanger s'installer sur la luge
trouver l'équilibré sur la glace rien
n'est simple
même quand on est passionné et à six
mois en arriver là on sait pas trop où
aller pour trop quoi faire
comment faire en fait pomme patiner en
fait pour rien faire là quand même on
arriva
c'est bon niveau quand on arrive à se
débrouiller la débrouille
le hockey luge est un sport encore
confidentiel en france
alors pour créer une équipe à cherbourg
il a fallu tout inventer et même
fabriqué les luges dans ce petit atelier
de créances dans la manche
auparavant les sols luge sur le marché
venait du canada elle j'étais hors de
prix en acte concret ça fait vraiment
qu'on est sur le projet on a mis tout ça
en place on a fait quelques prototypes
qui sont qui sont derrière qu'on a et
bacon a amélioré de au fil des essais
avec notre essayeur jean paul jean paul
est dans un fauteuil roulant depuis
quinze ans après une opération du dos
qui a mal tourné pour ce sportif de haut
niveau
le hockey luge ça ne rigole pas j'ai
fait de la luge et j'en fais c'est pour
la compétition c'est pour aller au à
l'image de jean paul on appelle six mois
l'équipe a vite progressé à chaque
entraînement il
désormais une petite dizaine sur la
glace sur la luge
il n'y a plus de handicap seulement les
sensations du hockey
avec maintenant on commence à voir un
normand de maîtrise et on prend plaisir
à se rentrer dedans
volontairement ils ont une sensation vie
cette vitesse qui ne peut ne peuvent
trouver dans aucun sport on voit des
personnes en situation de handicap avec
le sourire parce que ils s'éclatent sur
la glace c'est magnifique
cette saison l'équipe de hockey luge de
cherbourg effectué ses premiers matches
amicaux
dans quelques mois le club pourra tenter
l'aventuré en championnat trans est la
discipline est en plein essor
les clubs de hockey luge recrute partout
en normandie
[Musique]
suite et fin de notre fil rouge au
tournoi de tennis de bagnoles-de-l'orne
premier tour difficile pour le local
maxime forcin après s'être imposé dans
le deuxième set
le joueur s'effondre dans le troisième
quand trop de résistance
il s'incline 6 jeux à 2 et doit quitter
le tournoi dès son entrée en lice
[Musique]
une tactique en place avant le match et
je n'ai pas du tout suivi à la lettre
donc beaucoup de déception là dessus
après j'avais voilà je sentais pas très
bien la balle aujourd'hui donc j'aurais
pu m'accrocher et je n'ai pas faim j'ai
essayé de le faire et voilà c'est un
marché aux 2e 3e set manquée plus
délicat loin de chez lui c'est désormais
sur les tournois français que maxime va
tenter de retrouver son niveau 2 76e
droit français
[Musique]
ces sports c'est terminé pour ce
dimanche salut à tous et à bientôt